this tranquil farm in france's
countryside is thousands of kilometers
from the destruction in ukraine but
isabel le baler says collateral damage
from the conflict is being felt here on
her green pastures
today there is a direct impact on our
farm she says her animals eat grain and
le baler says the price per ton has more
than doubled since the war began not to
mention the sharp rise in the cost of
fuel and her inability to sell her
animals for more an equation she
describes as unbearable
cobit 19 labor shortages and inflation
have already contributed to a rise in
food prices and now a region often
called europe's bread basket is in chaos
together russia and ukraine account for
nearly 30 percent of the globe's wheat
and that's not all the three f's all are
impacted very highly food fertilizer
fuel the longer the conflict rages on
the higher the chance of food shortages
it will have a very very big impact on a
lot of asian and african countries
directly but throughout the world
indirectly in some way crippling
sanctions on russia have reduced supply
and on saturday poland's prime minister
proposed europe block all trade with
moscow
fully cutting off russia's trade would
further force russia to consider whether
it would be better to stop this cruel
war he said if there is something like
that full
trade blockade it will have a very
severe impact could canada increase its
wheat production to help fill the void
right now that question is difficult to
answer you know last year we had a
pretty bad drought the most recent crop
was short by about 7 million tons
farmers are hoping for better weather
but there's also a seed shortage rising
costs and a need to rotate crops even if
we produce
even the normal
amount of wheat that might still not be
enough to meet the global demand adding
yet another twist there's a looming work
stoppage at cp rail trains are vital for
wheat producers to get their products to
market three thousand workers could be
locked out early sunday if an agreement
is not met daya says canada's reputation
is at risk dan spector global news
ottawa